vous allez assisté à la chute
d'e il
était dans un
trempelin à exploser le paf'enol c'est s
exactement et
puis va
révéler un
dossier sur ce gar
son bien qui l'air bien sous ton rapport
bien sûr mais qui
est malheureusement bientôt papa bientôt
papa oui mais ça c'était avant
arrêtil que je pense malheureusement
qu'après ce que va dire Paula puisque je
suis allé la voir à la pub ah vous savez
ce que c'est oh je ne sais pas ce que
c'est mais elle m'a dit c'est un vrai
bail et c'est
chaud elle a dit je sais pas si je peux
le dire exactement et là je lui ai dit
si gé de l'annoncer là je lui dis si il
faut le dire Guillaume Janton moi aussi
j'avais des dossiers sur toi je ne les
ai jamais sortis hein oui j'ai des
dossiers sur toi je ne les ai jamais
sortis de quel type de type tu sais très
bien de quoi je veux parleri j'étais toi
je me feraai tout petit oui quand on est
en cavale on se
fait d'accord hein d'accord donc
considère qu' tu en Caval ok Paul SCA
bonsoir rideau là tout de suite non non
non non non Paska bonsoir bonsoir normal
bonsoir Paska alors allez plus fort
Paska Paska avant avant de vous laisser
entre de bonnes mains avec Pascal et
Laurent je vous rappelle quand même le
principe c'est qu'il faut quand même que
vous demandiez quelque chose donc vous
avez un dossier mais quelle est votre
demande à Guillaume derrière déjà palska
est-ce que Guillaume aurait pu aurait pu
être votre
style non non d'accord donc c'est pas ça
vous concerne pas non non ça concerne
une invitée féminine op d'accord qui est
venu il y a longtemps qui est venu il y
a pas longtemps et je peux juste dire
pour l'instant que Guillaume n'est pas
ind différent à son charme alors attends
attends attends attends dis-moi elle est
venue il y a combien de temps à peu près
après 3 semaines parisque ça fait 3
semaines que tu es revenu de 3 semaines
je pense tu as FEM t de combien quoi non
mais ta femme est enceinte de combien de
mois 6 mois 7 mois 6 mois 7 mois donc
apparemment dans les dates déjà un
problème
certain il y a un problème en tout cas
paulsa je tiens te féliciter pour ta
franchise merci pa ça fait déjà quelques
jours que j'ai envie de balancer et je
pense qu'il sait très bien de quoi je ve
parler parce qu'il m'a carrément fait du
chantage il m'a dit si tu dis pas je te
donne de l'argent s'il te plaît je sais
ce sont ces méthodes Paul
SC ce sont ces méthodes et on te croit
ici Pascal la et moi on te croit
vraiment sur
parole Pascal et Laur si vous
voulez est-ce que nous donner un petit
indice sur le niveau d'information que
vous allez nous donner ce soir
pense que vu que sa femme est enceinte
c'est quand même très chaud alors je
vais te dire
pasme on voit le degré tu sais
aujourd'hui les familles ça va ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vientagines ou pas le gars écoute tu
sais aujourd'hui pa les familles ça va
ça vient et si tu dois ce soir on se
décembre on est le
13 et bien le 14 ou le 13 si tu dois
briser la vie de Guillaume n'hésite
pas hor non je pense pas que ce soit
grave bah ça a l'air quand même non non
non non mais non je pense pasa parce que
tu me fais quand même un peu
peur je pense qu'il avait une bonne
raison de faire ça j'imagine elle rigole
pas raison de faire
prierut te parler je vais venir te voir
de petite seconde elle est en premier
degré pour tout salut c tu vas bien
complètement
c'est le BA damorce type
BA d'accord et c'est pas
tout je viens d'avoir les infos c'est
pas ouf
pour sur la tête de ma mère là je charie
pas les gars srieux je vais demander
elle s'appelle comment ta fiancée jade
jade je vais te demander d'aller prendre
un
bain
[Rires]
je vais te demander d'arrêter tout
contact avec la vie
extérieure la toche le téléphone les
tablettes tout ça e oh jade on enlève
tout ça ok on passe à autre choseie tu
vois on revient à la nature tu vois tu
prends ton téléphone tu le prends tu le
jettes contre un mur tu vois parce que
préférez pas annuler la séquence non
alors je vais vous dire pour des
raisons pour des raisons qui m'incombent
qui sont lesquels exactement
a des raisons de déontologie
journalistiqueintégrité certain éthique
géthique
généthique Paul est-ce que tu m'entends
oui c'est normal je suis juste
là regardez vous pouvez le voir parce
que c'est pas non plus un truc de ouf
Polska est juste là
ah avant que tu ne parles
Polska parce que je pense que ça va être
chaud parce qu'elle m'a dit un truc elle
m'a dit pas seulement Guillaume juste
est-ce que tu as je vais je vais un
petit peu casser le concept parce que là
c'est la première fois parce que là ça
va trop loin les gars ouis d'accord
c'est quelqu'un qui est en train de de
il y a ta femme qui fait couler l'eau
dans le bain là il y a sa femme surtout
qui vient de prendre un billet pour
partir très
loin est-ce que tu as quelque chose à
dire à Paska alors déjà j'ai toujours
été fidèle dans cette relation non non
non mais et Paska paulska tu peux
m'envoyer ton RIB et on
s'arrange quelle horreur moi j'ai une
autre question à poser à guum est-ce que
tu sais de quoi il s'agit non est-ce que
tu as en vrai regarde dans les yeux
est-ce que tu as un truc à te reprocher
et tu te sens pas à l'aise ce soir là
tout de suite je suis droit comme la
justice droit comme quoi la justiceère
écoute-moi bien je t'explique
alors je là c'est ton ami qui te parle
on oublie c'est plus le patron tu
n'entends ma voix il a que ma
voix tu es dans une merde noir tuass
quoi donc je t'explique dans ces CASL
oui tu sais il faut que voilà dis un
truc on is exactement je vais te dire tu
peux pas dire je suis blanc de blanc
ouais dis voilà il MRE arrivé euh tu
sais quand tu dis ça tu sais quand tu es
sur la
route parfois il y a des déviations que
tu vois pas arriver et tuas une route
tout tracée et puis là OK et ben c'est
ce qui t''est arrivé et tu t'es trouvé
sur un itinéraire bis mon
vieux tu sais quand tu es sur la route
parfois il y
a qui va arver Cyril si on si on
respecte le concept de l'émission il
faut que Guillaume nous dise s'il est
d'accord pour écouter pa peux dire non
encore mais est-ce que j'ai le choix B
non tu peux dire si tu es d'accord ou
pas quoi mais en même temps si tu dis
non tout le monde va penser qu' un gros
do je te donne un conseil quoi donc non
tu fais ce que tu veux mais c'est là
c'est l'ami qui te par B je préfère pas
alors donc tu ne veux pas écouter Paska
non pa ma
chéri je sais que tu av un gros dossier
sur
Guillaum
pa Paul je sais que tu as un gros
dossier sur Guillaume ma chérie il est
19h57 on est en direct et Guillaume a
pris a choisi de ne pas t'écouter Paul
SC mais je vais faire quelque chose que
je ne fais
jamais je dis bien
jamais et ce sera la dernière fois que
je feraiis ceci ou cela j'ai décidé en
mon âme et consci
ence de faire passer avant l'amitié et
c'est très rare que je le FE la vérité
la vérité bravo aujourd'hui ce soir la
vérité éclater est devant l'amitié ouais
vérité amitié et ensuite le reste
d'accord est-ce que tu veux le dire ou
pas déjà bah c'est vrai que je me dis
que grâce à cette vérité ils vont
peut-être surmonter beaucoup d'épreuves
ensemble c'est ce que je pense aussi
un poison
attendez attendez je je non là
franchement paulska je te le dis même
moi je suis actuellement
euh dans un
marasme et je ne sais pas quoi faire
quoi choisir comme je sais pas est-ce
que tu dois le dire ou pas je vais
revenir te voir de
visu ça peut durer 2 ans c'est
sympa c'est vraiment chaud C
histoire parce que sa copine était je
sais mais pour l'instant ce qu'on peut
faire c'est qu'en fait il y a les faits
et a la personne au pire pour l'instant
on peut dire l'un des deux ou les fait
ou la personne ouais comme ça on avance
compris ri compris je comprends pas ce
que tu es en train de me dire là la
personne concernée d'cord la femme
concernée d'accord ah oui ok paia ah
c'est une autre femme tu sais
qu'aujourd'hui on est dans un dilemme
avec les téléspectateurs les
téléspectateurs ils sont comme moi ils
ont envie de savoir et justement je vais
demander écoutez vous savez quand je ne
sais pas quoi faire je demande la vie
des
téléspectateurs je vais demander sur
Twitter est-ce que vous voulez gros que
Paul ska fasse des révélations sur
Guillaume Janton Guillaume Janton je le
rappelle non il peuent dire non
Guillaume Janton
2023 parti trop tôt petit ange petit
ange parti trop tôt Guillaume
Ganton il était venu dans cette émission
il était tout souri il disait j'ai envie
d'abattre des montagnes et
puis paulska est arrivé et Paula
elle n'a qu'une envie dans la vie c'est
Terminator tout dégommé casser la vie
des gens pourire la vie des chroniqueurs
et des invités c'est drôle je vais
demander si on a un premier avis sur le
sondage déjà pe-être que les gens vont
préserver Jade est-ce que les gens
veulent préserver jade est-ce que les
gens veulent préserver Guillaume ou
est-ce que les gens veulent préserver
the
truth g la vérité on aura des premières
indications dans une minute les Chéries
si vous nous rejoignez dans une minute
on aura les premières indications dans
une minuteok je dis bien j'ai compris ce
qu'elle voulait POC en fait elle voulait
soit vous dire le nom de la personne oui
c'est ça soit vous dire ce qu'il avait
fait les deux rappelle on rappelle Cyril
quand même que Guillaume Guillaume qui
est notre invité ce soir sur le plateau
on rappelle que il accepte d'entendre
cette vérité lui non
non
non mais c
dit Guillaume tu acceptes d'entendre
cette vérité oui j'ai pas le choix bah
oui te laisse le choix non il a dit non
oui oui oui oui oui oui oui oui il
accepte il accepte d'entendre cette
vérité maintenant c'est à paulska de
prendre cette décision attendez le
public le public et non pa après la vie
du public mais c'est PAA même si le
public dit non c'est PAA décide que
c'est oui la Seu l'unique personne qui
décidera de l'avenir de Guillaume et de
cet
enfant cet enfant qui va naître quand en
février un petit
poisson est-ce que le bébé ça risque pas
de le traumatiser dans le ventreil
entend ce soir quand même pas on ira pas
jusque là mais je pense que gu Laur je
je je je pense que c'est quand même un
truc qui peut remettre des des non non
je pense que ça peut aller non tu sais
ce c'est pas je crois malheureusement
oui je crois malheureusement on va voir
ce qu'en pense le public s'il vous plaît
alors ah ouais les gens ILT gens ils
sont sans pi public je vous aime vous
êtes à mon
[Rires]
image
merci j' l'attendeis pas moi de votre
part merci merci merci public qu'est-ce
que je vous aime non mais je vous jure
allez on va te voir donc va écouter pa
ça me qui décid pas on pe c'estelle qui
do décider PAA tu vas nous dire le gros
dossier de Guillaume parce que
maintenant il y a des règles le public a
choisi maintenant pa tu veux te [__]
tout le public à dos et tout Twitter à
dos n'hésite pas % ils ont dit oui oui
ils ont dit oui 70 % ma chérie c'est un
plébiscite
ok c'est Unis je décide de dire la
vérité non non non non elle décide de
dire la vérité et bien Paul
scar nouvelle venue dans l'émission qui
a déjà
demander sonondage à seolen royale oui
exactement et bousiller la carrière de
pas mal de gens qui sont venus ici oh
oui jou olska allez tu nous fais la
révélation sur Guillaume chanton ou pas
oui non alors il y a un petit problème
parce que tu es juste là à 1 m et je ne
t'entends pas oui voilà merci je faire
malaise il faut savoir aussi que je suis
pas folle he si je le dis parce que même
si maintenant on est en bon terme faut
pas oublier qu'il y a quelques moi de ça
je suis venu en tant qu'invité et
Guillaume m'a déglingué et moi je suis
quelqu'un de rancunier
ça va alors
pr
famille c'est pas le principe je le dis
c'est pas le principe ça tu es sûr que
tu veux pas un virement Paula non espè
on m'achète pas Paska tu te débrouilles
àc Guillaume ok alors d'abord je vais
dire les fait et ensuite je dire le nom
de la
personne donc déjà des faits c'est
horrible ça fait une semaine que
Guillaume il me parle que
d'elle et deuxièmement il lui parle sur
Instagram je crois que tu en as trop dit
désamorces ouais désamorces un peu quand
même tu es sûr que Guillaume Janton un
peu Mar qui la meuf tu s que c'est pas
Guillaume
Meurice bon je dis le nom de la personne
al non attends attends parce que non non
non c'est bon c'est bon donc tu parles
avec une meuf non
ou c'est un petit non ça c'est une vanne
quoi si c'est un sketch dites-le mais
c'est pour le
travail sûrement si je parle avecelun
c'est pour le travail est-ce qu'elle tu
me parles souvent d'elle hein quoi tu me
parles souvent d'elle
[__] bon allez c'est bon là quoi alors
je vous dire moi c cette séquence au
départ je l'ai fait en tout bien toute
honneur tu voulais faire plaisir au dép
terminé à 19h20 là ça a pris des
proportions Mme moi je ne contrôle plus
paulski Paul
Paul c'est Guillaume qui décide est-ce
que tu oui veux estce que tu veux
qu'elle dise le nom de la personne ou
pas ok mais si je lance un dossier sur
[Applaudissements]
PAH
gu pa je je je viens d'avoir l'info là
au dé beauté si j'étais
toice que tu
veuxc alors est-ce qu' cède à la
pression ou pas oui tu cèdes à la
pression mais j'ai rien à cacher ah
merde tu es sûr mais
oui mais j'ai TR envie de dire
maintenant ah
ouais décide alors moi je
pas j'ai rien avoir là-dedans Guillaume
est-ce que tu veux qu'elle le dise ou
pas oui bah ça dépend ce que ce qu'elle
souhaite pour la suite de sa passutre
chose aprèsprès toi demain tu tu lui
diras ah non tout de suite gu guillum on
peut poser une question à palska est-ce
que c'est une personnalité connue la
mise en cause palska
oui est-ce que c'est quelqu'un qui a
déjà vu sur ce plateau oui bah oui
est-ce que c'est quelqu'un qui é sur ce
plateau il y a pas longtemps oui et tu
étais présente non mais tu crois que tu
joues à qui a qui
toi c'est vra bravo bravo
vont s'embrouiller ici vont
s'embrouiller alors bon alors bon allez
elle le dit et tu tu lui diras de oui
lui c'est une personne je dis juste
après directement juste après je balance
une Dinger juste après c'est une
personne connue après fais bien
attention parce que tu t'es confié à moi
il y a pas longtemps oh là là attention
Guillaume c'est une personne connue
derrière tu as cru que tu allais me
terminer allezka Guillaume comme on
l'aime je le dis tu le dis tu es sûr
arrête c'est qui allez ok alors c'est
NON NON attention non il veut pas quoi
vasy sur le T c'est Auriel non c'est qui
Auriel mais
[Applaudissements]
pas oh
non c'est quoi c'est quoi le B ba ah oui
c'est quoi le BA n'importe quoi oh là là
c'est mais pas du tout non mais si c'est
vrai non non c'est vrai palsa est-ce que
c'est vrai ce que tu dis oui ça
s'invente pas ah ouais moi je vais
partir alors moi je suis écoutez moi ça
va trop
loin viens viens sur le plateau parceon
pe après il a le droit de la trouver
jolie très sympa en plus c'est
surprenant qu c'est vrai non je te jure
ah oui ah ça a mis un froid là c'est
grave tu peux aller t'asseoir et tu
viens tu viens de briser une
[Rires]
famille mais c'est vrai bah il peut
s'explique je lu envoyé un message pour
l'émission pour la féliciter parce qu'on
a parlé de French Shore dans l'émission
elle était là donc on le sait
oui qu'est-ce qu'il t'a dit exactement
dis-nous tout ce que tu sais producteur
j'en ai trop dit non non non c'est bon
là un peu de marge
encore non non il m'a il m'a dit juste
plusieurs fois queil a trouvé très joli
que ce truc en plus ça le dérangeait pas
et que ce truc c'est quoi ce truc c'est
quoi ce truc en plus non mais non mais
oui c'est c'est c'est là c'est c'est
compliqué c'est très bien bravo merci en
tout cas paulska voilà euh Guillaume
merci et je vais te dire tu peux dormir
à la maison tu peux dormir à la maison
ce soir après c'est un peu une infom
Médi c'est une infomédiat c'est ce
produit ça va E oh ouis non mais ça va
quand même allez on va passer maintenant
à autre sujet euh